toujours à toutes et à tous donc nous
commençons notre semaine avec nouvelle
série d'auditions de notre commission
d'enquête et nous reprenons nos travaux
aujourd'hui en recevant Monsieur Olivier
David qui est chef du service du climat
et de l'efficacité énergétique à la
direction générale de l'énergie et du
climat monsieur vous dirigez depuis 2018
ce service qui est une division de la
direction générale de l'énergie et du
climat la DGEC que vous représentez
aujourd'hui
auparavant vous avez été notamment
sous-directeur du système électrique et
des énergies renouvelables au sein de la
direction de l'énergie intégrée
également à la DGEC et cela de 2015 à
2018 votre audition doit nous permettre
de mieux comprendre le rôle de la DGEC
dans le pilotage de la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments afin
d'atteindre des objectifs que notre pays
s'est fixé votre direction placée sous
la tutelle conjointe du ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires et de la ministre de la
transition énergétique et chargée
d'élaborer et de mettre en œuvre la
politique relative à l'énergie aux
matières premières énergétiques ainsi
qu'à la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique et la pollution atmosphérique
plus spécifiquement la DGEC a pour
mission de proposer des mesures
favorisant la maîtrise de la demande et
l'utilisation rationnelle de l'énergie
pour l'ensemble de ces usages ce qui
inclut en ce qui concerne notre
commission d'enquête l'amélioration de
l'efficacité énergétique des bâtiments
à ce titre la DGEC et l'administration
qui est chargée du suivi des certificats
d'économie d'énergie les C2E qui
concentrent les critiques relatives à la
fraude et au malfaçons nous aimerions
donc connaître vos positions concernant
ces critiques et quels sont les
améliorations qui ont été mises en œuvre
ou que vous envisagez de déployer à
l'avenir après presque cinq ans à votre
poste vous êtes particulièrement
qualifié pour avoir une vision
d'ensemble de la politique de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments de la manière
dont sont fixés les objectifs et dont
elle est pilotée il ne serait précieux
que vous puissiez nous faire part de
votre diagnostic et des améliorations
que vous souhaiteriez voir aboutir
comment la DGEC agit-elle pour favoriser
la rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
comment cette action
s'articulent-elles avec les autres
acteurs de la rénovation énergétique
cette gouvernance est-elle selon vous
perfectible par ailleurs j'observe que
de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent pour
demander une dissociation entre la
décarbonation de l'énergie consommée
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone et
protéger le climat et l'isolation des
bâtiments afin de lutter contre la
précarité énergétique et de limiter la
consommation et donc la production
d'énergie cette dissociation vous
semble-t-elle pertinente enfin plus
généralement quelle analyse faites-vous
des politiques publiques actuelles en
matière de rénovation énergétique des
améliorations peuvent-elles selon vous
être apportées afin de rendre plus
efficace
et d'accélérer la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments avant de vous laisser la
parole pour répondre à ces premières
questions il me revient de vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'un compte-rendu
sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-1 14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende voilà aussi je
vous invite Monsieur le Chef de service
a prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie je vous laisse donc
la parole pour répondre d'ores et déjà à
cette première question plus le propos
que vous souhaiterez tenir au préalable
et en début de centre audition et notre
rapporteur ainsi que les membres de
notre commission ne manqueront pas à la
suite de vos propos de vous poser un
certain nombre d'autres questions je
vous laisse la parole bien volontiers
merci merci beaucoup madame présidente
mesdames messieurs merci pour votre
invitation devant votre devant cette
commission d'enquête
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit la
politique de rénovation énergétique
poursuit plusieurs objectifs et je pense
que vous êtes toute la complexité de
cette politique de
l'avoir plusieurs objectifs à la fois il
y a d'une part un objectif bien sûr de
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre le bâtiment c'est 18% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de la
France et donc il est essentiel d'agir
sur le bâtiment pour réduire nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
on a un objectif de baisse des
consommations d'énergie
qui
rejoint un objectif de baisse des
factures d'énergie et de ce qui est payé
par les ménages et aussi les entreprises
et les collectivités dans le cadre de
leur propre bâtiments
on a un objectif important de
lutte contre la précarité énergétique
qui
est complémentaire des objectifs de
baisse de consommation de désillusions
gaz à effet de serre et de baisse des
consommations d'énergie mais on voit
bien que quand dans la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique et notamment dans
la rénovation des bâtiments des ménages
très précaires qui du coup consomment
très peu d'énergie du fait qu'ils vivent
dans une dans une passoire thermique ou
un bâtiment très peu isolé on voit bien
que cette politique de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments peut conduire
à une augmentation de la consommation
d'énergie suite à la rénovation
et enfin on a quand même aussi un
objectif de confort des logements
d'adaptation au changement climatique
qui est aussi
présent dans la politique de rénovation
énergétique et qui est souvent le moteur
principal des rénovations la plupart des
deux temps les ménages font des
rénovations pas pour un objectif de de
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais aussi pour un objectif de
confort
pour ça on utilise l'ensemble des outils
à disposition et je pourrais y revenir
plus en détail à la fois des outils
financiers des outils d'aide qui sont
extrêmement importants avec
ma prime rénove on est sur
2,8 milliards d'euros d'aide par an dans
les différentes composantes de ma prime
rénov ma prime rénove pour les
propriétaires occupants ma prime rénove
sérénité imprime rénov pour les
copropriétés on a vous l'avez dit le
dispositif des certificats d'économie
d'énergie qui n'est pas propre à la
rénovation des bâtiments qui est bien un
dispositif universel sur l'efficacité
énergétique mais qui dans le bâtiment
représente de l'ordre de 3,7 milliards
d'euros pour le bâtiment dans la partie
logement et la partie tertiaire et on a
aussi une aide dont on parle peu qui est
la TVA réduite la TVA 5,5% sur les
travaux de rénovation qui représentent
cette fois-ci un coût fiscal de 2
milliards d'euros on voit que dans
financier on a vraiment ces trois outils
très divers un outil fiscal un outil
budgétaire qui m'imprime rénov et un
dispositif extra budgétaire et c'est à
dire des communes d'énergie on a aussi
les outils réglementaires
qui sont aussi qui existent aussi dans
le domaine de la rénovation des
bâtiments
le décret tertiaire qui est applique au
tertiaire et qui rend obligatoire des
baisses de consommation d'énergie on a
ensuite des outils récents
l'interdiction de location des passoires
thermiques qui a été introduit par la
loi climat résilience et qui rentre en
vigueur progressivement
l'interdiction d'installer des nouvelles
chaudières fioul c'est un décret qui est
rentré en vigueur le 1er juillet 2022
et donc on voit que progressivement on a
s'ajoute à des outils d'incitation des
outils réglementaires et enfin on a
toute une politique d'information
conseil et d'accompagnement parce qu'il
ne s'agit pas juste d'avoir des aides et
des obligations et on voit que les LED
et l'obligation de suivi pas mais on a
tout un tout l'état des sujets
d'accompagnement
vous m'avez interrogé sur le du coup sur
cette un peu cette dichotomie entre
belles émissions de gaz à effet de serre
et baisse des des consommations
d'énergie pour nous les deux objectifs
sont vraiment liés c'est-à-dire que
l'objectif qu'on poursuit c'est bien la
neutralité carbone en 2050
c'est vraiment le gérer le phare de
notre politique énergétique et
climatique mais je dirais les deux
soupliers enfin les deux conditions de
l'atteindre la notoriété carbone c'est
bien la baisse des consommations
d'énergie
on n'arrivera pas à atteindre cette
neutralité carbone baisse des
consommations d'énergie et la sortie des
énergies fossiles c'est que l'objectif
c'est bien en 2050 de que qu'on ne
consomme plus y compris dans le bâtiment
de fuel ou de gaz naturel pour se
chauffer dans le bâtiment
et donc on voit bien que baisser les
consommations d'énergie ça veut dire
baisser
les
émissions gaz à effet de serre ça veut
dire baisser les consommations d'énergie
et prioritairement baisser les
consommations d'énergie fossiles donc on
a bien une politique basée sur ces deux
piliers baisser les consommations
d'énergie et sortir des énergies
fossiles ça guide aussi nos actions de
rénovation cette sortie des énergies
fossiles dans le bâtiment
les objectifs ils ont été fixés
au niveau européen et on les a déclinés
au niveau français c'est et ils ont été
récemment rehaussés par le paquet de
fortify notre objectif précédent c'était
moins 40% des missions de gaz à effet de
serre en 2030 par rapport à 90 et on est
en train de rehausser significativement
cet objectif à moins 55 % net ce qui
nécessite d'accélérer notre politique de
rénovation la politique de rénovation
elle
porte ses fruits en matière de baisse
des missions gaz à effet de serre
on a dans le bâtiment c'est 65 millions
de tonnes de CO2 en 2022 et on observe
une baisse continue ces dernières années
depuis 2017 les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ont baissé de 22% dans le
bâtiment c'est à dire ça correspond en
gros à 4,5% par an on était
grosso modo sur le rythme à atteindre
pour atteindre notre objectif de baisse
de gaz à effet de serre qui nécessitait
une baisse de -4,6% par an des émissions
de gaz à beter dans le bâtiment on voit
qu'on était grosso modo sur le bon
rythme
par contre la hausse de l'objectif 2030
nous oblige à accélérer
la baisse des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans le bâtiment puisque
entre maintenant et 2030 il va falloir
baisser de 45% nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre des ratins d'un rides en
gros de 5,6% par an on voit qu'il faut
qu'on il y a une accélération à faire
suite à l'augmentation de l'objectif
dans la baisse des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
la politique française donc je reviens
un peu sur cet objectif qu'on compare
avec nos voisins européens
on voit que tout le monde a à peu près
la même politique isolation est sorti
des énergies fossiles avec quand même un
certain nombre de différences avec les
autres enfin on voit que c'est une
politique qui est difficile à mettre en
œuvre dans l'ensemble des États membres
de l'Union européenne
d'ailleurs le Haut Conseil pour le
climat puis avait publié il y a un an ou
deux un rapport de comparaison de ces
politiques entre les pays européens on
voit qu'on a à peu près tous les mêmes
difficultés qui consiste à convaincre
les ménages de s'engager dans des
travaux de rénovation énergétique et
tous les États européens utilisent à peu
près les mêmes outils des outils
d'incitation d'obligation et
d'accompagnement en France dans le
logement on utilise surtout de
l'incitation et peu d'obligations et on
voit qu'on était
peut-être un peu en retard sur
l'accompagnement
par rapport notamment aux Allemands qui
ont des dispositifs d'accompagnement des
ménages dans la rénovation globale qui
sont sans doute plus performants que les
nôtres et j'y reviendrai c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire avec mon accompagnateur
rénov on a par contre une grande
spécificité une spécificité marquée dans
la politique en France c'est que c'est
un politique de rénovation énergétique à
un caractère social extrêmement fort ce
que n'ont pas un nombre de pays
européens
ce qui d'ailleurs d'un certain point de
vue n'est selon les objectifs qu'on
poursuit n'est pas forcément gérer le
plus efficace pour réduire nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en termes
puisque le niveau d'aide pour pouvoir
déclencher des opérations et de
rénovation est beaucoup plus importante
sur les ménages très modestes que sur
les ménages aisés mais on a clairement
et ça c'est énormément renforcé depuis
2017 un volet social à notre politique
de rénovation énergétique très fort
c'est
c'est notamment ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on
fait dans les C2 mais ce qu'on a fait
aussi dans
dans
ma prime rénove si je fais un petit zoom
sur le logement le logement dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est le logement c'est deux tiers des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
bâtiment
et 80% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est le chauffage et quand on
zoome sur le chauffage un tiers des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre du
chauffage c'est le chauffage fuel et en
gros deux tiers le chauffage gaz le
chauffage fuel c'est en gros 2,5 à 2,8
millions de chaudières pour 30% des
émissions tandis que le chauffage gaz au
gaz naturel il y a 12,5 millions de
chaudières pour 60% des émissions on
voit que là où il y a un gisement
d'émissions gaz à effet de serre très
fort c'est bien sur le chauffage fuel
dans le bâtiment et donc c'est depuis
2017 une des autorité forte de la
politique de rénovation c'est
d'essayer de
[Musique]
pouvoir sortir du fioul dans le domaine
du bâtiment
et donc c'est vraiment nos deux piliers
sortir du fioul dans le domaine du
bâtiment et isoler les bâtiments en se
concentrant sur les passoires thermiques
les passoires thermiques les FG c'est 17
% du
parc de logement
si on voit que si on arrive à la fois à
rénover l'ensemble des passeoirs
thermiques là où on a des gains de gaz à
effet avec une énergie les plus
importantes et de sortir du sortir du
chauffage fioul c'est là où c'est là où
les gisements en termes d'économie
d'énergie et de baisse de gaz à effet de
serre sont les plus importants et c'est
comme ça qu'on a essayé d'orienter nos
systèmes d'aide
nos systèmes d'aide donc c'est bien sûr
ma prime rénov que vous connaissez qui
qui est ma prime rénov qui est un
dispositif
un dispositif récent
on a tendance souvent à l'oublier quand
on parle de dispositif c'est un
dispositif qui a été créé en 2020 pour
les ménages modestes et très modeste et
en 2021 qui a été élargi à l'ensemble
des ménages
parfois j'irai les critiques de
dispositif ont tendance à oublier ce
caractère extrêmement récent de
qui est qui a forcément dispositif qui
est monté en puissance de façon
extrêmement rapide puisque
dès le début
on a eu un nombre de demandes
extrêmement élevé ces dispositifs qui
remplacent le cite
avec deux avantages dans ma prime rénov
enfin deux caractéristiques c'est qu'on
va pouvoir toucher la prime beaucoup
plus rapidement donc il y a un centre de
critique sur le fait que on touche la
prime trop lentement mais il faut pas
oublier que dans le cite
on faisait les travaux une année on l'a
déclaré sur sa déclaration d'impôts
l'année suivante
il pouvait y avoir il y avait il y avait
12 à 18 mois entre le moment où on
engageait l'argent et au moment où on
touchait les travaux c'est des délais
qui sont certes toujours trop long pour
les ménages mais qui ont été
considérablement raccourcis dans ma
prime rénove puisque on peut avoir ça ça
prime au bout de quelques mois et enfin
c'est un dispositif qui a été énormément
recentré sur les ménages modestes 70% de
ma prime rénov est consacrée au ménage
modeste et très modeste ce qui n'était
pas du tout le cas de du crédit d'impôt
transition énergétique qui était
concentré sur les ménages
pour qu'elle déménagent les ai touché
l'essentiel du crédit d'impôt
c'est un dispositif qui a permis de
faire
plus de 700 000 rénovations en 2022 avec
différentes avec plusieurs piliers ma
prime rénov sérénité qui est un
dispositif d'accompagnement et qui
permet des rénovations plus profondes
dans lequel il y a eu 15000 dossiers en
2000 excusez-moi 34 35000 dossiers en
[Musique]
2000 en 2022 ma prime rénov copropriété
qui est un dispositif spécifique
d'accompagnement des copropriétés là
aussi qui permet des rénovations
profondes et qui monte fortement en
puissance si on a eu 25000 en 2022 et
enfin ma prime rénove je dirais par
geste dans lequel il y en a eu 630 000
en 2022 qui permettent pour beaucoup des
changements de chauffage
des installations de pompe à chaleur en
gros qui permettent de quitter des
chauffages
ou gaz pour installer des pompes à
chaleur y compris des pompes à chaleur
hybrides du chauffage biomasse mais
aussi qui permet de faire de l'isolation
des murs
dans ma prime rénove
par geste les enjeux sur ma prime rénove
c'est
de je dirais pouvoir progressivement
augmenter les rénovations globales par
rapport aux rénovations par gestes avec
de l'accompagnement
c'est le pilier ma prime rénov sérénité
qui qui joue ce rôle d'un condiment par
gestes et l'idée c'est en informant les
ménages de
d'accompagner d'accompagner
progressivement
les ménages vers de des rénovations plus
profondes
à la DGC on oppose pas un rénovation par
geste et rénovation plus profonde il est
c'est aussi utile de pouvoir changer
de pouvoir faire des gestes d'isolation
de pouvoir faire changer sa chaudière
notamment quand on change une chaudière
quand je passe par exemple d'une
chaudière gaz à une pompe à chaleur
hybride on va diviser par trois sa
consommation de gaz on va on va baisser
sa facture
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'est aussi des gestes qui sont
utiles même si on est très attentif à ce
que dans l'installation de pompe à
chaleur on est un certain niveau
d'isolation du bâtiment ça c'est ma
prime rénove notre grand pilier notre
deuxième grand pilier c'est les
certificats d'économie d'énergie
dans lequel on est sur un dispositif
extra budgétaire qui repose sur les
fournisseurs d'énergie qui doivent faire
faire des économies d'énergie avec deux
caractéristiques dans ce dispositif ce
qu'on appelle dans notre jargon le rôle
actif et incitatif c'est-à-dire que
c'est un dispositif qui est très
construit sur l'Allée Verte c'est-à-dire
que c'est il faut c'est pas on obtient
pas d'économie d'énergie après faire les
trains après avoir fait les travaux en
regardant les aides auxquelles on a
droit c'est bien une aide qui doit
déclencher des travaux ça c'est une
caractéristique très importante du
dispositif et l'autre caractéristique
c'est que c'est un dispositif qui a
aussi un caractère redistributif
puisque
c'est les C2E le coût des c2o est
prélevé sur
sur la la facture des
des Français mais bénéficient beaucoup
plus au ménage précaire qu'aux autres
ménages donc je dirais les ménages
précaires sont bénéficiaires net des C2E
alors que les ménages les plus aisés je
dirais pas eu plus de ces deux œufs dans
leur facture qui reçoivent
collectivement en termes d'aide sur les
C2
c'est un dispositif qui est extrêmement
important pour
les la rénovation jusqu'à quelques
chiffres en 2022 c'est 625000 isolations
de combles c'est
170000 isolations de plancher 150 000
isolations de murs c'est 155000 pompes à
chaleur qui ont été soutenus on voit
qu'on est sur des chiffres assez massifs
également en termes de de gestes de
de rénovation qui sont effectuées grâce
aux certificat des Comines d'énergie
[Musique]
la valeur qui est attribuée elle est
liée aux économies d'énergie réalisée
sauf deux exceptions on
accorde des bonifications qui
correspondent aux priorités que j'ai
indiquées avec ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon des professionnels en termes de
communication nos fameux coup de pouce
on a deux types de coups de pouce les
coups de pouce chauffage qui répondent à
notre priorité de sortir des énergies
fossiles donc qui dans lequel on va se
soutenir plus des ménages qui
abandonnent qui passent d'une chaudière
fioul ou gaz vers un chauffage ENR de
type pompe à chaleur ou
chauffage biomasse ou réseau de chaleur
et notre deuxième priorité c'est la
rénovation globale on a un coup de pouce
rénovation globale dans lequel quand le
ménage s'engage en innovation globale il
va recevoir plus de ces deux œufs que ce
qu'il aurait dû dans un calcul de l'Éc
onomie d'énergie réalisée
vous avez parlé des fraudes
c'est alors sous le terme de fraude on
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de situations
diverses qui sont
qui sont
constatés donc c'est un terme générique
qui recouvre beaucoup beaucoup de
situations
il y a on observe dans le C2E on a
observe aussi dans le dispositif de
markim Renov
on a des fraudes je dirais deux types
fraude purement au dispositif
c'est-à-dire donc il impacte pas les
ménages en quelque sorte c'est à dire
des gens qui vont demander des cd2e pour
des travaux qui n'ont jamais été faits
ça je dirais c'est des fraudes qui sont
intrinsèquement liées au dispositif
enfin qui sont
même plus on a des fraudes qui sont liés
aux opérations de rénovation avec tout
un panel de fraude
à la fois des fraudes qui sont liés à
des sujets de consommation
c'est à dire que des des articles des
professionnels qui vont vendre des
travaux
sans avoir l'accord express de
de la personne qui va faire les travaux
souvent en leur vendant un crédit
associé sur ça aussi les fraudes qui
sont je dirais ce qu'on observe aussi
dans plein de dispositifs de démarchage
qui sont pas propres à la rénovation
mais qui sont
ce qu'on retrouve dans plein plein de
situations de la vie courante et on a
ensuite des fraudes entre guillemets qui
sont liés à des malfaçons dans les
travaux
qui avec là aussi on a tout le tout le
spectre
de
fraude je dirais de travaux qui sont
clairement
très très mal fait à des petites
malfaçons
et donc on a tout le spectre c'est pour
ça que ce terme de fraudes recouvre une
situation extrêmement diverse
dans lequel la lutte contre la fraude et
pour nous une préoccupation on dirait
constante puisque
on
[Musique]
a en permanence à lutter contre la
fraude
dans cette lutte contre la fraude on
déploie
donc on a eu une montée en puissance
très forte des C2E dans les années
2018-2020 dans lequel cette montée en
cette montée en puissance très forte et
rapide c'est accompagné d'un afflux de
fraudeur important souvent les fraudeurs
notamment
des repères des dispositifs qui montent
en puissance rapidement pour pouvoir
s'engouffrer dans le dispositif et donc
on observe c'est dans l'esprit des C2E
une très forte baisse des fraudes depuis
je dirais un an ou deux
par rapport à ce qu'on observait dans
les années 2018 2020 comment est-ce
qu'on a pu
j'irai faire cette baisse des fraudes
d'une part en
s'organ en augmentant très fortement le
niveau des contrôles avec deux types de
contrôle
des contrôles qui sont réalisés par les
énergéticiens avant qui déposent les C2E
avec des obligations de contrôle
important
des contrôles sur site
10% des opérations qui sont réalisées
par les énergéticiens doivent faire
l'objet de contrôle sur site donc très
concrètement c'est quelqu'un c'est un
bureau de contrôle qui se déplace là où
là où ont lieu les travaux
pour pouvoir vérifier à la fois que les
travaux ont été faits et la qualité des
travaux donc c'est quelqu'un qui c'est
10% des travaux et ce qu'on a rendu
obligé donc c'est au moins 10% et ce
qu'on a rendu obligatoire c'est aussi
les travaux les contrôles ce qu'on
appelle par sondage par plutôt par point
de contact c'est 20% des des travaux
doivent être contrôlés par point de
contact donc en plus des 10% qui sont
contrôlés sur site ce qu'on appelle des
travaux par point de compte par des
contrôleurs points de contact c'est ça
prend la forme d'un coup de téléphone ou
d'un courrier avec réponse des gens chez
qui on a fait les travaux dans lequel on
doit leur demander est-ce qu'ils ont
bien eu des travaux et comment c'est son
passé les travaux et est-ce qu'ils ont
satisfait des travaux donc ça permet de
contrôler moins de choses qu'en allant
sur site puisque notamment
les ménages sont pas experts et donc ça
pas forcément répondre sur la qualité
des travaux mais en tout cas s'ils ne
sont pas satisfaits des travaux et s'il
y a des malfaçons ils vont le dire par
téléphone bien sûr chaque contrôle
négatif ou chaque point de contact
négatif donne lieu à des corrections des
travaux donc on a
quasiment un tiers des C2E qui sont
déposés qui ont fait l'objet de contrôle
et ensuite on a nos propres contrôles
qui sont faits par l'administration par
le pôle national des certificats
d'économie d'énergie dans lequel là on
n'est pas sur des contrôles aléatoires
mais on est sur des contrôles ciblés
dans lequel par toute une série
d'indices et d'informations on va nous
aussi faire les mêmes types de contrôle
donc envoyer des bureaux de contrôle sur
place vérifier avec des travaux et faire
des contrôles par point de contact là où
ça s'est beaucoup amélioré c'est qu'on a
atteint on a interrogé 10 000 ménages
bénéficiaires de ces deux œufs et on a
une note médiane de 9 sur 10
aussi bien sur la qualité des travaux
que sur le dispositif des C2E donc on a
des ménages qui sont globalement très
satisfaits
des travaux qu'ils ont eu
bien sûr
on a toujours il y a toujours des
problèmes il y aura toujours des
problèmes qu'on essaye du coup de
repérer
à la fois par le dispositif de
signalement
donc les gens nous envoient des
signalements
en nous disant directement qui sont qui
sont pas satisfaits de leurs travaux
mais aussi une autre action qu'on a
menée c'est
un renforcement extrêmement étroit je
dirais de l'ensemble des services de
l'État qui agissent sur ces sources
contre la fin qui lutte contre la fraude
donc la DGEC avec notre peau nationale
et comme énergie
les services de la DGCCRF sur les sujets
de consommation
les services de police et de gendarmerie
mais aussi euh traque fin puisque on est
parfois confronté donc là on parle pas
de fraude de fraude je dirais de
malfaçon mais vraiment là de fraude au
C2E
et on travaille étroitement avec Lana
qui pilote ma prime rénove et les
organismes
de certifications qui accorde les
les certifications RGE dans lequel c'est
aussi un échange d'informations qui
descendent la relation qui permettent
d'orienter les travaux RGE tous ces
échanges d'informations peuvent se faire
grâce aux modifications législatives qui
ont été apportées dans la loi énergie
climat de 2018 dans la loi climat
résilience en 2021 on a maintenant on
peut maintenant échangé de façon fluide
tout en respectant le secret bien sûr
des informations qu'à chacun vis-à-vis
de l'extérieur de nos informations
je suis un peu long peut-être un mot
aussi sur le reste à charge qui est
aussi un point important avec le
dispositif d'écho PTZ qui monte en
puissance fortement il y en a eu 80 000
en 2022 mais aussi le prêt avance
rénovation qui est une nouveauté la loi
climat résilience qui monte en puissance
on n'a pas encore de chiffres mais il
monte en puissance
un point important au delà des
incitations c'est l'information conseil
donc on distingue bien nous
l'information conseil de
l'accompagnement
l'information conseil c'est
des
lieux ou des points de contact que ce
soit physique ou par téléphone
dans lequel les ménages peuvent obtenir
des informations et du conseil sur
la rénovation
c'est un dispositif qui est qui est
copiloté avec les collectivités c'est le
réseau France rénov dans lequel l'ANAH
sur le pilotage complet dispositif et
c'est c'est bien copiloter et cofinancé
par les collectivités c'est en gros 55
ans 55 ans de l'argent donc qui vient
des C2E du programme Sarr et 50% qui est
apporté par les collectivités que ce
soit les régions les obliques notamment
les régions et les EPCI et un tout petit
peu les départements
dans quelques situations
ça ça a beaucoup beaucoup monté en
puissance depuis 2019
aussi bien en nombre de conseillers
qu'en espace France rénov on couvre
maintenant la quasi-totalité du
territoire 98% du territoire il y a
encore des sujets dans certains
départements d'outre-mer mais j'irai en
France métropolitaine on couvre
l'ensemble du territoire et on est passé
de 700 conseillers en 2019 à 2300
conseillers aujourd'hui donc on voit
bien la monter en puissance très forte
de ce dispositif d'accompagnement
conseil
c'est qu'en 2022 450
000 ménages qui ont fait l'objet d'une
information dans ces espaces et 225 000
qui ont fait l'objet de conseil donc
certains s'informent juste puissent à
l'information et d'autres passent au
conseil donc c'est 225 000 ménages qui
ont été conseillés
c'est un dispositif qui est bâti sur un
programme C2E Sart co-construit et
comporté avec les collectivités
programme qui s'arrête fin 2024 et donc
on a ouvert depuis début mai une large
concertation avec les collectivités pour
pouvoir définir ce que sera ce
dispositif
France rénov pose 2025 dans lequel les
principes qu'on a mis sur la table c'est
à la fois une de garder ce copilotage
avec les collectivités de garder ce
qu'au financement avec les collectivités
et du côté de l'État ça sera des
financements budgétaires qui prendront
la suite du programme C2E et l'idée
c'est bien de pouvoir poursuivre cette
mise en cette mise cette montée en
puissance de cette information conseil
qui est important
ce qui débute par contre c'est
toute la mission d'accompagnement là on
est différent de l'information conseil
là l'idée c'est vraiment d'accompagner
le ménage concrètement dans ces travaux
dans la dans le choix des entreprises le
suivi des travaux et la réception des
travaux et
cet accompagnement et pour nous
absolument essentiel si on veut
gérer aller vers beaucoup plus de
rénovation globale puisque un ménage
seul un ménage a besoin d'être
accompagné pour aller dans la rénovation
globale alors l'accompagnement existe
déjà à la fois dans ma dans ma prime
rénove sérénité qui est déjà fait déjà
l'objet d'un accompagnement pour les
ménages modestes
dans ma prime rénove rénovation globale
qui existe pour les ménages
je dirais intermédiaire et supérieur
les espaces France rénove faisaient déjà
de l'accompagnement s'ils ont fait 20
000 accompagnements en 2022 donc il y a
aussi de l'accompagnement par ces
espaces France rénov mais l'idée c'est
j'irai d'accélérer fortement et
d'augmenter très fortement le nombre de
ce qu'on appelle les mondes
accompagnateurs rénov donc cette
profession qui existe déjà mais qu'il
faut qu'on développe et qu'on
développe fortement qui va accompagner
ces ménages et donc ces accompagnateurs
rénov seront
agréés par l'État donc c'est un
dispositif mis en place par la loi
climat résilience dans quel l'ensemble
des textes réglementaires sont ont été
publiés et Lana est en train d'agréer
accompagnateurs rénov donc on peut dès
maintenant déposer son dossier à Lana
pour pouvoir
je dirais être agréé mon accompagnateur
rénov et l'objectif c'est qu'à partir de
quand on ouvre qu'on a des aides à par
exemple on a les aides ma prime rénov
rénovation globale
c'est ces aides soient face
obligatoirement l'objet d'un
accompagnement donc il y aura un
accompagnement obligatoire quand on fera
on aura de la rénovation qu'on aura des
aides pour faire de la rénovation
globale et l'objectif c'est d'augmenter
très fortement le nombre de rénov pour
que progressivement
j'irai on puisse
quand un ménage se dit je vais faire de
la rénovation par geste qui puisse avoir
que qu'il puisse aller vers
l'information conseil et que
l'information conseil dans lequel soit
ça se justifie pas par exemple
il a un logement qui est très bien isolé
avec une chaudière gaz là l'information
conseil va lui dire mais si vous
installiez par exemple une bac hybride
au lieu de votre chaudière gaz vous
feriez des économies et vous auriez des
aides vous pourriez aussi réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre à ce
moment-là il sera orienté vers un
professionnel de la pompe à chaleur
hybride comp
mais s'il lui dit je voudrais changer de
chaudière mais j'ai un loche j'habite
dans une passoire thermique là
l'objectif c'est que l'information
conseil l'oriente vers mon armateur
rénov avec les aides spécifiques et donc
on puisse je dirais créer ce canal qui
existe déjà mais qu'on veut massifier
vers la rénovation globale
donc c'est vraiment l'enjeu qui est
devant nous là dans les dans les 6-12
mois qui viennent c'est on a l'ensemble
du cadre réglementaire c'est d'augmenter
très fortement le nombre de je dirais de
professionnels mon aquariateur rénove
donc c'est professionnel existe déjà
dans les dispositifs il y a déjà tout un
socle de professionnels notamment c'est
des professionnels qui sont qui font
l'accompagnement dans sérénité et c'est
beaucoup de personnels de personnes dans
les espaces France rénov qui font déjà
de l'accompagnement
donc qui sont qui sont je dirais notre
socle de
de mon accompagnateur Renov
je sais pas si vous utilisez un mot du
tertiaire peut-être je suis un peu long
non non mais c'est très intéressant je
pense que pour l'heure on va peut-être
s'arrêter là de façon à ce que le
rapporteur vous pose peut-être un
certain nombre de votre question si des
membres de la commission veulent
également et puis à la fin peut-être
parce que c'est moi l'objet de notre
commission sur les tertiaires monsieur
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Chef du de service pour vous
à la fois vous explications c'est vrai
que sur le tertiaire même si on va dire
ça nous intéresse aussi mais du coup la
commission d'enquête est plutôt ciblée
sur toute la question du logement et qui
est déjà
un gros sujet donc on va peut-être en
rester là non moi j'avais plusieurs
plusieurs questions d'abord sur
peut-être sur la l'Observatoire de la
rénovation puisque vous faites partie de
la gouvernance si vous pouvez nous nous
en dire quelques mots parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un outil qui est
relativement neuf donc on a on a reçu on
a déjà auditionné mais voir votre avis
sur le fonctionnement en fait de cette
de cette observatoire des premières
analyses en tout cas des premiers
chiffres qu'il a pu qu'il a pu produire
et du coup si ça vous paraît un outil
intéressant en tout cas satisfaisant et
et à poursuivre
ensuite j'avais des questions donc sur
vous avez beaucoup parlé des C2E
sur le et sur le fonctionnement
des C2E c'est vrai que peut-être on se
pose un peu la question et vous l'avez
chaud très bien dit dans votre dans
votre explication sur le fait qu'il y
avait plusieurs dispositifs ma prime
rénove et puis à côté on avait ce
fonctionnement des C2E qui parfois n'est
pas forcément très lisible en fait à la
fois de l'extérieur et pour les
personnes qui veulent
travailler sur la rénovation sur la
rénovation thermique de leur logement de
savoir à qui s'adresser comment et
d'avoir de la lisibilité donc ce qui est
des orientations en tout cas des
réflexions pour faire en sorte que c'est
deux dispositifs puissent d'en faire
qu'un même si derrière il y a des choses
plus complexes à mettre en œuvre mais en
tout cas de qui est peut-être qu'une
seule porte d'entrée et puis surtout ce
qu'on voit parfois c'est des
orientations en tout cas des indications
qui peuvent être contradictoires entre
ce que peut faire ma prime rénove qui en
tout cas dans son orientation va plutôt
sur de la essaye plutôt d'accompagner
vers de la rénovation de la rénovation
globale
mais en même temps avec les C2E vous
l'avez dit où on a des opérations
ciblées sur mes combles à 1 € sur les
chaudières et donc qui en fait oriente
directement en fait vers un seul geste
parce que c'est vrai que quand on fait
une opération comme les combles à 1 € ou
juste cibler sur une chaudière forcément
on va plutôt pousser en fait à faire ces
gestes là donc je voulais avoir votre
avis un petit peu sur la cohérence en
tout cas entre le fonctionnement de ces
deux ces deux dispositifs
également peut-être c'est vrai que vous
en avez pas beaucoup parlé mais sur la
question du confort thermique d'été et
c'est vrai que c'est une question qu'on
se pose aussi beaucoup sur
toutes ces questions de rénovation
thermique c'est que pour l'instant on
parle beaucoup effectivement de du
confort hiver et en tout cas les
déperditions énergétiques mais sur le
confort d'été dont on sait que c'est
quelque chose qui va être de plus en
plus prégnant et qui a un impact aussi
énergétique puisque sur les
climatisations sur le fait aussi des
pompes à chaleur qui peuvent être
réversibles et donc tout l'intérêt aussi
d'avoir cette cette réflexion en tout
cas en amont quand on quand on fait de
l'isolation et donc sur les types de
matériaux et c'est vrai par exemple que
sur ma prime rénov beaucoup de
dispositifs liés à la
au confort d'été que ça soit des
casquettes solaires que ça soit des
stores etc ne sont pas ne sont pas
éligibles en tout cas ne soient pas pris
en compte est-ce que c'est des
réflexions du coup que vous pouvez vous
pouvez avoir
et puis sur l'accompagnateur
l'accompagnateur Renov vous en avez
également également parlé en distinguant
bien effectivement la partie on va dire
conseil première approche et puis
ensuite l'accompagnateur Renov qui est
plus dans le on va dire dans
l'opérationnel en tout cas dans dans ce
qui l'orientation de ce qu'il faudrait
faire sur la rénovation
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore eu
réellement de chiffres et de savoir cet
accompagnateur rénove en fait on se pose
quand même beaucoup de questions sur son
[Musique]
sur ce qu'il fera réellement en fait et
qu'elle sera sa mission et c'est vrai
que suivant ce type d'émission ça peut
être très différent et si c'est vraiment
un accompagnement je dirais pousser
assez assez
véritable accompagnement justement vers
de la rénovation globale et un vrai
conseil avec avec une étude et une étude
énergétique on sait que ça peut coûter
un certain montant de 3000 euros mais on
entend aussi parler de prestation qui
pourrait être aux alentours de 150 200
euros ce qui du coup pas du tout la même
chose et qui est pas du tout la même
chose dans les orientations et dans ce
que pourrait faire c'est
d'accompagnateur
rénov donc savoir si du coup voilà vous
pouvez nous éclairer en tout cas sur
quel est le quel serait le but et
l'objectif et puis savoir en fait si
justement suivant ce montant là est-ce
que c'est quelque chose qui serait pris
en charge totalement c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui fait ce choix là et qui se
lance dans une rénovation est-ce que du
coup ce le coût de cet accompagnateur
Renov puisqu'il deviendrait obligatoire
si on est sur de la rénovation globale
est-ce que il serait pris en charge
intégralement
voilà c'était mon autre autre question
et puis je crois que pour l'instant j'ai
fait le tour déjà dans un premier temps
merci merci beaucoup je suis président
de Monsieur rapporteur
alors sur le NRE l'observateur de la
rénovation énergétique
donc c'est
alors la statistique publique
s'intéressait déjà à la rénovation et au
bâtiment avant la création de manière e
donc c'est c'est pas c'est c'est
on a créé cette observatoire mais on l'a
créé beaucoup à partir de de
travaux déjà existants l'objectif c'est
quand même de sanctuariser
un je dirais un certain nombre de
travaux qui permet d'éclairer sur où
est-ce qu'on en est en matière de
rénovation énergétique avec
la mise en place de tableau de bord et
d'indicateurs donc qui sont publiés
régulièrement sur le site du ministère
et la publication d'un certain nombre
d'études qui sont faites spécifiquement
par l'on re
l'objectif de l'ONU donc c'est bien de à
la fois donc tous les travaux de l'on re
sont publics
ils sont ils sont mis sur le site
internet du ministère avec un centre de
travaux qui ont déjà été publiés à la
fois sur l'état du parc
où est-ce qu'on en est dans l'état en
termes d'étiquettes de l'état du parc
que ce soit le parc de logement mais
aussi ce qui a été publié récemment
c'est le parc de logement
qui est mis à la location on n'a pas
tout à fait les mêmes étiquettes entre
le ce qui est mis à l'occasion et ce qui
est le parc global avec toute une suivie
de consommation d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre du parc de logement donc
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
est très précieux et surtout ce qui est
précieux c'est que c'est des travaux
dans la durée ça veut dire qu'on a des
premières études qui ont des publiées
mais l'objectif c'est de pouvoir les
faire régulièrement
tous les ans
dans lequel qu'on puisse suivre
l'évolution
et les effets des politiques publiques
qui sont menées
avec des travaux dans lequel l'objectif
c'est aussi d'avoir des données le plus
rapidement possible ce qui est toujours
un peu frustrant dans les données
statistiques en matière d'énergie de
climat c'est que
on a souvent les données avec un deux
ans de retard
et donc ce qui rend compliqué le
pilotage de la politique quand on sait
deux ans après l'effet de ce qu'on a
mené et donc un des grands enjeux de
l'on re c'est aussi
de voir comment par des méthodes je
dirais sans doute moins fiables que
j'irai les méthodes de statistiques
utilisées précédemment qui continueront
à perdurer mais qui dans lequel on a
besoin d'une très grande durée avant
d'avoir des chiffres consolidés pouvoir
avoir des chiffres provisoirs de façon
beaucoup plus rapide pour mesurer
l'effet des politiques
et enfin un travail très important
qui est en train d'être mené par l'on re
c'est de se demander quels sont les
économies d'énergie réelle d'un certain
nombre de rénovations
donc de façon statistique en utilisant
les outils Linky et Gaspard qui
permettent d'avoir des mesures
extrêmement fiables et je dirais avec un
pas de temps réduit
en général le pâton du mois
suffit d'avoir des des
mesures de consommation d'électricité et
de gaz et le travail qui est en train de
mener l' on re c'est d'essayer de
rapprocher
les bâtiments qui ont fait l'objet de
rénovation et d'observer
les économies d'énergie réelle avant
après pour voir
quelles sont mesurer quels sont les
effets réels des travaux des énergies
donc c'est un travail de grande ampleur
parce que il y a énormément de biais
statistiques on voit bien que un
logement vide qui a fait l'objet de
rénovation
et qui a ensuite été occupé va voir sa
consommation d'énergie augmentée entre
avant et après pourtant il peut être
passé de façon thermique un logement
très bien isolé il y a tous les sujets
de changement de la taille du foyer donc
c'est un travail qui nécessite du coup
un nombre statistique très important
de logement qui ont fait l'objet de
rénovation il a aussi ses avaient parti
du type de travaux que mène l'on re donc
c'est vraiment extrêmement satisfaisant
donc c'est pour notre vie très précieux
sur les C2E
alors c'est un outil qui est vraiment
différent de ma prime manœuvre qui est
pas un outil budgétaire
donc on a vraiment deux d'un côté au
début budgétaire de l'autre un outil
extra budgétaire avec des
mécanismes un peu différents
on a aussi la force des C2E c'est qu'on
a cette allée vers des énergéticiens
qui ne doit pas aller vers
[Musique]
du
démarchage agressif donc c'est toute la
vie enfin c'est aussi un point important
toute la limite entre
je dirais proposé des travaux de
rénovation énergétique et le démarchage
abusif mais là il y a aussi eu toutes
une série de dispositions législatives
contre le démarrage téléphonique qui
porte ses fruits
donc les deux dispositifs ont leurs
avantages et leurs inconvénients
l'objet c'est bien pour nous que ce soit
le plus fluide possible pour les ménages
avec
des critères qui sont donc on a fait une
part du travail et qu'on est en train de
finaliser des critères qui sont
exactement
identiques c'est à dire que
ce qui pour nous est un problème c'est
quand une isolation des murs par les C2E
et une isolation des murs par ma prime
rénove on n'a pas on n'a pas les mêmes
critères
là pour nous c'est pas acceptable ce
qu'il faut c'est qu'on est exactement
les mêmes critères et donc on a
identifié encore quelques cas où c'était
pas le cas donc ça va se c'est des
textes qui sont qui vont être publiés
d'ici l'été pour qu'on a exactement les
mêmes critères
ensuite ce qu'on l'idée c'est que
ce soit plus fluide possible pour les
ménages donc on puisse les on puisse
avoir des dossiers qui soient les plus
proches possible entre les deux et enfin
pour les gros travaux
ça sera aussi le rôle de mon
accompagnateur rénov
d'accompagner les ménages dans aussi
cette partie demande d'aide
mais il y a aussi
[Musique]
notamment les professionnels des C2E
accompagnent beaucoup les ménages dans
la demande de ma prime rénove c'est à
dire que quand ils vont
proposer des C2E pour faire des travaux
à un ménage ils vont en général proposer
le package c'est de eux ma prime rénove
et Eco PTZ c'est un peu les il y a les
trois piliers les aides disponibles plus
le financement et c'est
Lana a créé ce qu'on appelle les
mandataires MPR c'est-à-dire c'est ces
professionnels qui sont beaucoup des
professionnels dc2e qui vont pouvoir
accompagner les ménages dans la demande
de leur de leur C2 donc l'idée c'est
bien d'avoir ce mécanisme le plus fluide
possible
[Musique]
à la fois avec Laurence c'est ce
rapprochement qu'on opère entre ces deux
œufs et MPR même si ça reste deux
mécanismes distinct l'idée c'est qu'il
soit le plus rapproché possible sur mon
armateur rénove
l'idée c'est bien que ce soit un ménage
ce soit un professionnel qui aide le
ménage à définir ses travaux qui a
choisi des entreprises à
suivre les travaux et à réceptionner les
travaux c'est une c'est une mission
d'accompagnement à maîtrise d'ouvrage
complète donc on n'est pas sur ça du
tout sur 150 euros on n'est pas non plus
sur 3000 euros nous dans nos estimations
on est plutôt sur 1500 à 2000 euros
en termes de coût que représenterait
cette prestation de mon acmateur rénove
1500 à 2000 euros dans le cas général
parce qu'on prévoit que
il y a une sorte de prestation
complémentaires
notamment
pour des ménages très précaires dans
lequel
l'accompagnement à la rénovation doit
s'accompagner aussi d'un accompagnement
social dans ce cas là on a un coût qui
est qui est bien supérieur mais dans
lequel il est important aussi pour nous
que
je dirais les
le monde a combien de rénove soit formé
à cette partie sociale alors tous ne le
feront pas mais en tout cas qui sachent
la détecter et orienter vers on aura en
gros des Renov spécialisés qui pour
accompagner les ménages très précaires
l'objectif c'est bien que l'État prenne
en charge une partie du coup de mon
inconvénateur rénove donc ça fait encore
ça fait partie de la concertation qui
est lancée
les principes les principes de cet
accompagnement ça sera que
le pourcentage d'accompagnement sera
beaucoup plus important sur les ménages
très modestes et modestes que sur les
ménages aisés donc on aura un pour on
aura à la fois un plafond
d'accompagnement un plafond de dépenses
qui sera qui sera entre 1500 et 2000
euros et un pourcentage un pourcentage
pris en charge
par l'État
avec un pourcentage qui sera plus
important sur les ménages très modestes
que sur les ménages ce que sur les
ménages aisés
donc ça ça fait encore l'objet de
concertation et de réflexion que ce soit
opérationnel à l'été
juste pour bien comprendre du coup la
compagnateur rénove il serait
obligatoire dans lequel une rénovation
globale tout à fait et donc le risque
est pas va pas être justement de
d'éloigner en fait le choix vers une
vers une rénovation globale puisque en
fait si on dit aux gens
vous allez avoir du coup l'obligation de
prendre une maîtrise d'oeuvre un
accompagnateur Renov qui a un coût donc
on va dire aller entre 1500 et 2000
euros pour l'instant on sait pas la
prise en charge mais ça veut dire que il
y aura forcément du coup un reste à
charge et donc quelque chose en plus et
donc du coup plutôt je dirais avoir un
effet qui qui peut faire un peu
l'inverse et à certaines personnes de se
dire ouais je vais faire je vais faire
l'économie de de la maîtrise d'oeuvre en
passant vers du geste du simple geste
alors on le alors il faut
le voir globalement sur le coup sur le
coup mon accompagnateur rénove plus les
travaux c'est-à-dire que c'est
ce qui compte pour le ménage c'est
combien il va dépenser
combien il va dépenser dans l'opération
globale donc il aura il aura le reste à
charge qui compte c'est celui qui l'a
sur l'ensemble il a pris en charge qui
compte c'est la prise en charge entre
demain et de rénov et des travaux on
peut se poser la question de pourquoi
est-ce qu'on prend pas en charge à 100%
mon incompatiateur rénove
ça rejoint à
ça rejoint un peu le sujet des combles à
1 €
les comblains en euros ça a été permis
par une bonification importante
d'essayer de eux pour cette opération
c'est une opération qui a porté ses
fruits puisque ça a permis l'isolation
de plus de 2 millions de maisons
individuelles dans l'opération des
combles
donc ce qui est une opération
d'isolation extrêmement efficace
quand on a des combles perdus
d'isolation mais inversement on voit que
quand le ménage ne paye rien
[Musique]
l'avantage c'est qu'il a pas de reste à
charge et où ça permet de massifier un
sens des aubergonovation inversement
quand il paye rien
il est beaucoup moins attentif à
la qualité des travaux à aller de
travaux qui sont faits puisque je
voudrais c'est que du bonus puisqu'il
n'a rien payé
c'est une question qui se pose beaucoup
sur mon accompagnateur rénov qui est je
dirais une prestation encore plus
complexe à vérifier que des combles à un
nœuds que des colisolation des comptes
puisque les isolation des combles après
les travaux on peut aller voir on peut
aller voir quel travaux ont été faits
les travaux
contrôler une prestation intellectuelle
ça va être aussi un défi de lutter
contre la fraude dans mon incarnateur
rénov on est bien conscient que mon
armateur rénove il y aura bien sûr plein
de professionnels
la majorité l'immense majorité des
professionnels
seront sérieusement le travail de mon
amateur enov mais on est bien conscient
que c'est une niche concret avec un
système d'aide en face dans lequel il va
falloir lutter très fin de façon
extrêmement efficace et extrêmement
sévère contre eux un centre de fraudeur
qui vont se dire à l'état nous a créé
une niche nouvelle avec une haine
nouvelle dans lequel on va pouvoir par
une intellectuelle dans lequel il y a
forcément cette prestation
intellectuelle un déficit de
connaissance entre avec le ménage
c'est-à-dire que le ménage sera pas
forcément qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
doit lui apporter mon acmanateur rénov
et dans lequel l'idée c'est pas que le
ménage se dise
toute façon c'est payé à 100 % la
prestation il a pas fait grand chose
mais comme comme j'ai rien payé en fait
c'est pas très grave et donc c'est pour
ça qu'on s'oriente vers une prise en
charge qui sera très importante pour les
ménages très modestes mais quand même
avec un reste à charge ce sujet de la
prise ce sujet je dirais de la prise en
charge à 100%
des avantages des inconvénients et un
sujet quand même compliqué dans les
travaux de rénovation par rapport à la
fraude
sur les orientations pourquoi du coup ce
que tel que je comprends la compagnateur
rénov en gros c'est une maîtrise
d'oeuvre du coup avec une prise en
charge voilà
ce qu'on s'aperçoit quand même si on
veut aller vers la relation globale si
on veut pousser vers la rénovation
globale c'est souvent le manque
d'information au départ c'est quelqu'un
qui va commencer et notamment justement
avec que ça soit site internet etc où on
va nous orienter sur des combles à 1 €
sur changement de chaudière sur fin
toutes les prestations en fait comme ça
et donc du coup en fait va ne pas
forcément orienter les gens vers la
rénovation globale et souvent le manque
qui peut y avoir c'est juste une petite
étude qui permet à quelqu'un de savoir
et de se dire bah oui moi dans ma maison
j'ai peut-être intérêt dans un premier
lieu d'immy d'isoler mes combles et de
commencer par ça ensuite de faire mes
je sais pas mes menuiseries et puis
ensuite mes façades et puis à la fin de
changer ma chaudière et d'avoir à la
fois cette ordre dans les interventions
et puis une petite étude sur ses
prestations là qui permet ensuite avec
cette connaissance là de pouvoir
s'orienter de se dire bah voilà et je
sais que ça ça va me coûter une
prestation globale j'en sais rien 50.000
euros et donc je vais aller vers une
vraie donation globale et là du coup je
vais peut-être me tourner vers une
maîtrise œuvre qui existe déjà en plus
enfin il y a des gens qui sont des déjà
des professionnels pour ça mais je
trouve que du coup la première phase en
fait d'accompagnement et je le dis parce
que je trouve qu'il y a pas mal de
collectivités qui avaient travaillé sur
la question et à travers des plateformes
de rénovation avait ce système là c'est
à dire des gens indépendants en lien
avec l'ADEM ou voilà qui orientait et je
trouve que ça avait cette cette
facilité en tout cas et surtout cette
confiance parce que on savait que
c'était quelque chose de totalement
indépendant et donc du coup des gens qui
étaient informés et qui du coup
faisaient plus facilement le pas d'une
rénovation globale ou en tout cas ne
faisait pas d'erreur dans l'ordre en
tout cas d'intervention des de leurs
prestations quoi non mais je parle tout
à fait mais pour nous du coup c'est
vraiment les trois étapes j'allais les
trois enfin c'est un peu technocratique
comme comme séparation mais il y a
l'information le conseil et
l'accompagnement donc l'information
conseil enfin je pense que vous dites
c'est plus pour nous ce qu'on appelle le
conseil c'est à dire que c'est mais le
conseil il est extrêmement lié avec les
collectivités puisque on est sur le
réseau français-nov
autant pour nous l'accompagnement n'est
pas peut être plus peut être fait
par des agents publics ou des AD ou aide
financé par des collectivités liées on
va dire ça existe parce que ce que vous
dites mais c'est pas forcément
ça peut être aussi des des prestataires
privés autant l'information conseil
c'est le pour nous le réseau France
rénov et effectivement notre enjeu c'est
que toute personne qui se
qui se lance dans des travaux de
rénovation
et un point de contact avec un espace
France rénov ne serait-ce que parce que
ne serait-ce que l'idée c'est que il se
dit je veux isoler mes combles ce qui
est pas forcément qu'est-ce qui peut
être une bonne opération
parce que pour des tas de raisons que
il est systématiquement ce contact au
moins d'informations avec l'espace
entraîneur donc avec l'enjeu c'est de
massifier serait le réseau France énorme
ce qui est qui est en phase de
croissance pour qu'il y ait au moins
cette étape d'information
l'information pouvant déboucher sur le
conseil si mais c'est encore une fois si
le ménage le souhaite le conseil étant
là pour lui dire vu votre situation
installé une pompe à chaleur dans votre
passeport thermique là vous faites une
erreur massive
après il peut y avoir des tas des encore
une fois des tas de situations
particulières du ménage
soit ils s'oriente vers une rénovation
globale soit pour des raisons
ils ne souhaitent pas le faire mais qui
peuvent être bonnes souhaitent pas le
faire il va faire de l'isolation un peu
d'isolation échanger échanger sa
chaudière et ensuite de pouvoir passer
du conseil à
l'accompagnement mais l'objectif c'est
bien d'avoir ces trois étapes et de
convertir au maximum le passage de l'une
à l'autre pour le moment dans les
chiffres on voit qu'une personne sur
deux qui fait appel à l'information
va vers du conseil
le réseau France France rénov quand vous
dit du coup de massifier le c'est quoi
le l'ordre c'est quoi une agence par
intercommunalité il y a quelque chose
qui a été alors
ce qu'on a quasiment c'est une une
agence par EPCI
un point un point France rénov par EPCI
c'est pour nous le minimum après
alors on l'a quasi on l'a quasiment
atteint on l'a quasiment atteint cet
objectif de mais effectivement c'est
c'est vraiment un objectif fort d'avoir
il y a le cas d'outre-mer qui est qui
est à part
ok
il y a vraiment des des spécificités
dans lequel on n'est pas enfin il y a
clairement des départements d'outre-mer
où on est certain dans certains
appartements on est quand même très en
retard
sur ces sur ces dispositifs
mais avec aussi des spécificités dans la
rénovation voilà et donc c'est c'est
vraiment la conception de la
concertation qui est en cours qu'on a
lancé début mais avec les collectivités
qui est de voir comment est-ce qu'on
massifie
il peut
on pourra qu'on se fixe collectivement
avec les collectivités des objectifs
aujourd'hui c'est au moins un espace par
EPCI mais après selon les situations ça
peut être ça peut être beaucoup plus
très bien est-ce qu'il y avait encore
des questions du rapporteur non
est-ce que nos collègues
non pas d'autres questions et bien
écoutez on vous remercie si vous voulez
quand même nous faire parvenir quelques
éléments ça tertiaire
on est à votre entière disposition merci
beaucoup monsieur chef de service merci